[Music]
this is a Jabalia public announcement we
are now on podcast so go ahead and check
the description box below and you can
click that link and check it out and you
could hear us in your ear hole it's
gonna be awesome propaganda make sure
you leave five stars please because you
know why now on to the video
reach out it is submitted by Leila loves
the bails oh thank you fix me I was
stuck on the song layla catch me on
there you go eric clapton i don't know
how it really goes oh but thank you so
much
mental health experts are concerned of
an increased risk of suicide contagion
after celebrity suicides oh this is a
sad [ __ ] [ __ ] dog cuz it's like
a lot of [ __ ] happening like that [ __ ]
you noticed and thinking Kate Spade
Anthony build on with so many people you
think it happened because a cake Spade
and then he got slab because a case
plate and then he got to die because
well we know that Kate Spade was
obsessed with Robin Williams's death
hole in micro because I heard about that
chain reaction among a group of friends
it's a high probability that if someone
close to you does the suicidals within
that group someone that should go
oh yeah Chris Cornell and then our
Chester from Lincoln Park yeah your
anger
so all these celebs that's a lot of
celebrities within the past year yeah a
lot of them that's crazy
was Robbie Williams 20 18 or 20 17 14
[Laughter]
no 28 2014 within the five years it's
all one to me yeah in 2014 there was a
10% increase in suicide that's about my
committee an additional 1841 cuts
recorded in the United States and the
four months is like worldwide epidemic
sheet-like not just celebrities
I just wanted to peer myself because I
was like was Robin really okay so was
Robin Williams death that his suicide
was dad sad like that much that the
whole world was a United States other
people started killing themselves
if mrs. Bell I just gotta emphasize you
I'm just like in shock that I had to go
Wow
is that what really happened I'm just
[ __ ] bolding your [ __ ] texts
increasing the font size of what you
just said I turned that [ __ ] from a 10
to a [ __ ] 24 well you've been
talking yourself for three minutes
straight crazy Ellie's good to me guys
downtown LA yeah and only close to
800,000 people they die due to suicide
every year which is about one person
every 40 seconds so suicides a big
globally 800,000
you know I wonder if like you know just
because of like technology now we can
actually find a consensus of how many
people have been killing themselves I
wonder like if if it really is like an
increase or if it has it wasn't even
more back in the day you don't you don't
know it wasn't you know people just buy
so in the u.s. from 1999 to 2016 there
was a 30% increase in 25 states is it
also population increase I mean I guess
you can I don't know I don't know how
they determine I mean we are we are more
populated now than ever so it's just
statistics are just gonna increase the
point of it though is just kind of
saying like if someone that has
influence on you goes then you're more
likely well that's what I'm not sure if
that's the case like I don't want to
like feed something that's not like yeah
cuz it could be like hey check it out
there's a lot of baby boomers and
they're aging and they're at this age of
crisis level and a lot of them are
committing suicide because they're
losing family members not because Robin
Williams did like that right you're not
yeah like I just I don't want to not be
dismissive of this I just don't want to
like make something bigger than it
actually is in the sense of like I just
don't you know for us to especially cuz
you know a lot of people watch this I
don't want people to bill oh my god more
people kill me you know I mean yeah I
don't think it's trying to say causation
I didn't just the correlation like after
a Robin Williams passed away there's
there is uprise it's good link could be
not linked but we don't know but there
is a correlation somehow what is this
term called something suicide
correlation suicide or population
suicide contagion contagion can be
contagious suicidal contagion cease your
[ __ ] mouth and your word must be the
coffee
Nova yeah they're saying that they have
studied suicide contagion in schools
military units groups of friends and
families because following the exposure
of a suicide or suicidal behaviour in
these groups it can
they're saying that I can kind of spread
I get it could you you are kind of each
other's hope for living yeah so I can
also see like let's say you have five
idols right and if all five of your
idols pass away and then you're like
there's that one yeah that's damage of
an impact or two of your best friends
kind of normalizes it like it makes it
it makes it um more understandable for
you to like be like okay I get why they
do that they were close to me and I know
them yeah it makes sense for me to want
to do the same thing later of us I have
never had suicidal thoughts before so
it's it's I don't know how life even
when they're like eight or six I would
never ever ever once in my life wanted
to kill myself yeah but I can empathize
United mean because your religion no I
just I just I like myself like no matter
what I was going through no matter how
much like [ __ ] I was going through being
poor bullied or whatever I never thought
about killing myself I thought about
killing other people that made me feel
bad
yeah so maybe I'm not suicidal but
homicidal thoughts but I never thought
about killing myself
what's the Kanye Kanye line in the new
album uh what was it he said I love
myself more than I love you you know I
mean so you know that's kind of like
that type of [ __ ] so it's like if I die
you get to win okay so you die well I
felt suicidal as a kid because the
people that I felt homicidal towards
were my parents like they made me like I
didn't really I think maybe people that
haven't had it maybe they had a safe
zone myself that that bullies if you
don't feel safe and okay call my parents
make me feel safe or if I hate my
parents I got close friends or whatever
I think as a kid I hated my parents a
lot and they made my life suck ass to
the point where I'm like there's no
point in living I just felt like I
wasn't even living my own life and I'd
really had me a choice or anything oh
[ __ ] I have no idea what that's it maybe
that's why you know even though your
parents were rough on you they always
had the balance of love you never felt
that as a kid but that kids who are
neglected or feel abandonment or
anything like that they they're more
susceptible to suicide because you know
that's who you live for like I guess
like the only thing I could say that's
close to that would be like me like
saying like you know
I'm gonna run away and see what happens
to me dude but I'm trying to do that so
I could hurt then though yeah I mean
it's not because I don't want to kill
myself like the end goal wasn't for me
to die though yeah it was I was gonna
run away and be richer like I want it
like the way my mind was working was
like I'm gonna kill myself or I just
want to die and then that's gonna hurt
my parents you would like to hurt them
with yeah I was like [ __ ] I'm gonna
kill myself and really see who comes to
my funeral but but you're right though
about like kids being neglected like
when they're younger and stuff because I
have a few friends that were neglected
and they do have Susan I'd be like you
didn't come to my recital well they
actually had a music school so that's a
bad example but they were always at the
recital browser you don't come to my
[ __ ] graduation if I die will you
come to my funeral or would you be busy
working [ __ ]
what graduation did you have I graduated
the fifth grade or sixth grade no fifth
grade I went to junior high I didn't
graduate junior high I didn't graduate
high school so this was my fifth grade
graduation public you want to bet your
parents are suicidal didn't pass junior
high I the past [ __ ] high school I
[Laughter]
didn't go I didn't walk for college or
you know I did I get the finish but you
didn't give a [ __ ] about walking no I
was already like too old and too ready
to go
you're not even too old right now you
know but at the time oh you thought you
were I am what I am older than a typical
college student like I already
experienced life were like you know so I
went there cuz I need a degree so I
could upgrade myself and get a better
job which did a [ __ ] happen I didn't
fart okay yeah and it costs money you
know you got to get like people to come
and [ __ ] damn dude that's a lot they
give you free tickets like dude take it
stick really
I didn't even deal with the Magister
I saw the price and I'm like damn I
gotta pay for a roll
don't they rent these [ __ ] out
or something they do that's the price oh
you'll get to keep it
I mean you get to keep the couch man you
know I do kind of regret it though cause
I wanna not not nothing not the moment
not the moment okay yeah I just want the
[ __ ] cape I don't [ __ ] care three
of them over there but it's not the
graduation cable it is it's a hundred
percent the graduation
it's a gallon dude or the captain down
wait what keeper are you talking about
no the [ __ ] gal the graduation guy we
have white and black I think you might
want you and then cuz my brother has
that triangle at the velvet ass triangle
hat that's all [ __ ] he kept that [ __ ]
and his friend signed it and I'm like
[ __ ] ball to square that's [ __ ]
triangle shaped right and you put the
point I survived not suiciding yeah I
probably did so much [ __ ] drugs that
was so self-destructive I think like
it's really hard to do soo it's like you
got to really have some [ __ ] balls
like to blow your brains out to eat some
done of pills so like I think the
closest thing to suicide that a lot of
us do is like self-destruction
you know binge drink [ __ ] just get
crazy wasted slow suicide yeah I kind of
like run away from our problems and
thoughts and [ __ ] you know and I think
we all been there but it's
it's really cool now that people are
more open about it because back then
it's like you're a little [ __ ] or
people don't even know how to deal with
you were crazy you're nuts yeah you're
either no one else talks about it so
just the fact that you're you're the
only one thinking these thoughts then
you're crazy and you should never tell
anyone we're now like you said it's dope
that it's so public and everyone's
really sharing all of their you know all
of their struggles that people can
relate to and I feel like that's really
important to just get it out of your
head like it out of your head just say
it say it all yeah so if you're in the
u.s. and you want someone to talk to you
can call one eight hundred two seven
three talk or if you're outside of the
US you can check out International
Association for suicide prevention and
brief renders worldwide go talk to
someone you need to talk to somebody
that could help you
[Music]